so was geht hier vor max und herzlich
willkommen zum heutigen video
ich war die letzten tage in köln unter
anderem bei dem video days und ja es hat
sich so ein bisschen was verändert im
vergleich zu den letzten jahren so
normalerweise war das so man ist
irgendwie so rumgelaufen und da hat man
irgendwie leute schreien hören weil
irgendwo super großer youtuber da vorbei
gelaufen ist und alle vollkommen
ausgerastet sind aber dieses jahr ist es
mir irgendwie immer öfter passiert dass
leute voll ausgelastet sind und ich
stand mir so wer zur hölle ist das dann
habe ich herausgefunden dass ich bei den
personen um user handelt also um leute
die die musical app benutzen und dort
bekannt sind so da ich mich da mal ein
bisschen umgeschaut leute ich kann das
nicht kann nicht nur reden
ich bin nach wie vor unter schock da
habe ich mich da mal ein bisschen
umgeschaut leute und man sich das
prinzip von der app ganz nice also man
hat irgendwie ton datei sei es musik
oder ein sketch oder sonstwas und film
dass du sein eigenes video das jetzt
lippenbewegungen bei so sachen wie dem
daniel oder sowas geht es auch weg oder
aber irgendwie so dein lieblings lieb zu
dem du dich bewegst und zum film ist auf
jeden fall habe ich mich ein bisschen
umgeschaut in der app und da ist aktuell
eine sache im trend also in meinen augen
man kann musik mögen man kann es nicht
so mögen was mich angeht ist es nicht so
100 prozent mein ding aber manche sachen
sind ganz nett so aber dann gibt es
trends und ein trend zur zeit ist
einfach eclair in meinen augen
ich habe dazu auch schon mal auf twitter
was geteilt und der heißt hashtag just
waiting euro ab was dieser trend ist da
sind leute auf musical die filmen oder
fotografieren jede menge bilder als
kleine kinder von sich selbst
dann kommt ein beat drop und sie filmen
sich wie sie die kamera schicken also
wie sie so wie soll ich sagen indem sie
sich selbst feiert übelste fühlen und so
den ihr machen und so also richtig
kritik schlimm
damit ihr wisst worum es geht habe ich
gedacht ich nehme es auf mich und wir
gucken uns ein bisschen was davon an
weil wenn man video davon handelt müssen
natürlich auch wissen worum es geht also
leute ich habe mir extra gemüse tee
herunter geladen wir schauen uns das
ganze jetzt mal an
ok also dass du dieses grundprinzip
leute tanzen und sonstwas und die musik
wird halt im hintergrund
gespielt ihr seht es hier hashtag just
waiting euro ab es ist so übel leute
macht euch ja was gefasst also wenn man
das dorf kommt die top music ließ zu
dieser challenge und ja das geld gab
sich dass so jemand jemanden kennt als
krimi das ist so eine
das kennt man so halt wenn man
amerikanische youtuber schaut sag ich
mal
aber ja wir haben uns das mal an die
kamera ist okay aber jacob stories ist
in diesem fall sogar noch ganz in
ordnung wie guck mal weiter
du bist du bist noch nicht fernab ist
auch 10
jetzt halte auch zehn exklusive hydro
abgesagt grown ups merkt ihr dass leute
es ist sogar ob die zeigen erstmal
erstmal ist es voll keine dran finde ich
so dieser ton aber so just white crow ab
und dann wartet man sie sind erstens
brauchen ab und zweitens kommen sie an
so eine kamera bisschen bis ich meine
leute gibt richtig gutes machen leute
ist es einfach grässlich wird wir tun
uns noch ein zwei mehr an das jetzt
junge ist es echt in meinen augen so der
beschissene trend dienst zur zeit gibt
so ein bisschen selbstdarstellung ist ja
vollkommen normal jeder post so ein
bisschen auf seinem instinkt oder so
aber das ist einfach so pure
selbstverherrlichung ich finde es
grausam
es ist doch einfach nur noch schrecklich
oder
guck dir mal an
aber diese ist ja das ist echt hässlich
leute konnte später nur schrecklich man
die lässigkeit fühlte es ist vorbei ist
es aus leute habt ihr das gesehen was
ist das für ein b
was war das denn die kamera ist ja an
das wusste hier gar nicht
was ist das denn leute macht es ich mach
das ist meiner
okay ich habe davon erst mal genug leute
jetzt ist es landen erst mal was mir
diesen trend aufregt ist dass der
einzige sinn darin besteht sich geil zu
fühlen ist er vollkommen in ordnung dass
man sich irgendwie schön fühlt und
zufrieden ist mit seinem körper aber was
vermittelt dieser trend wird wir
wahrscheinlich gesehen dass die nutzer
von musical relativ jung sind und dann
sind irgendwelche leute dann den trends
die zu den hier machen so oder ich habe
auch schon andere musicals gesehen wo
sich die kellys irgendwie so halb
ausziehen also also gerade so dieses
hier so dass den kleinen mädchen zum
beispiel bitter halt voll vorgespielt so
von wegen
du bist nur meine und so da gibt es ja
auch den einen oder anderen kandidaten
der das auch auf seine social media
plattformen so hey ich liebe dich und so
wisst ihr das finde ich halt einfach
voll krass also ja für mich ist das
definitiv einer der schlimmsten internet
trends seite don't judge me challenge
geht ja noch irgendwie ursprünglich was
damit zu tun gehabt dass nicht über
leute aufgrund ihres aussehens geurteilt
wird was im endeffekt einfach nur
gemacht wurde weil alle haben einfach
nur diese diese dinger wieder gemacht um
sie irgendwie geil zu fühlen
falls euch fragt wo ist der eigenanteil
so du hast jetzt ein paar musicals
angeschaut und so ich rufe jetzt selbst
zwei neue challenges ins leben und zwar
als erstes die just waiting up challenge
die funktioniert so geht auf texas sweet
light
guckt sich ein heftiger straight to grow
up musici an und übergibt sich
das ist eigentlich so meine challenge
bei meiner zweiten change handelt es
sich um die just waiting on the
challenge und ihr ahnt es schon
ich kombiniere die zwei schrecklichsten
challenges die das internet je gesehen
hat
okay das war wirklich schlimm dass
aufzunehmen und dafür dieses ganze zeug
mehr zu machen
ich hoffe mal das video hat euch
gefallen und lasst mich wirklich
unbedingt wissen wie ihr dazu steht zu
dieser ganzen geschichte ich finde das
ultra ultra strange und schlimm dieses
zeug ja das war's von heute macht's gut
und bis zum nächsten mal